[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kaiser
richter und marietta slomka
weihnachten steht vor der tür und
omikron leider auch besser gesagt das
ist schon da der neue corona expertenrat
der bundesregierung empfiehlt daher
einhellig dass es zusätzliche kontakt
beschränkungen gibt am besten schon in
den nächsten tagen am dienstag soll es
eine bund länder beratung zur wohnanlage
und weiteren maßnahmen gegen
gesundheitsminister lauterbach hatte in
der ard zuvor allerdings einen harten
lockdown vor weihnachten ausgeschlossen
bei unseren nachbarn den niederländern
gelten solche verschärfungen ja schon
seit heute zu weihnachten darf man dort
nur noch vier gäste zu besuch haben er
ist eine september hatten den
niederlanden zahlreiche beschränkungen
fallen lassen warum omikron jetzt nicht
nur die niederländische regierung zum
umdenken zwingt berichtet annegret oster
das war's mit dem weihnachtsbummel die
niederlande seit heute im harten
lockdown bis zum 14 januar soll der
dauern zunächst schuld daran ist omikron
in amsterdam etwa verdoppelt sich die
zahl der infektionen alle zwei bis drei
tage jede vierte corona infektion dort
ist eine mit der neuen virus variante
der siegeszug von omikron genauso
beeindruckend wie beängstigend
zuerst aufgetaucht in südafrika
mittlerweile gilt das gesamte südliche
afrika als virusvarianten gebiet und in
europa ist deutschland von hochrisiko
gebieten quasi umzingelt seit
vergangenen nacht sind noch dänemark und
frankreich hinzu gekommen und ab morgen
gilt großbritannien sogar als
virusvarianten gebiet so prominent
omikron bereits ist so wenig genaues
weiß man bislang feststeht die
virusvariante ist deutlich ansteckender
als delta je nachdem wie viel stärker
könnte mitte februar die inzidenz bei
bis zu 700.000 fällen liegen täglich
über die schwere der krankheitsverläufe
bei omikron gibt es noch wenig
belastbare daten aber wir gehen schon
davon aus dass auch omikron zu
gefährlichen klinischen verläufen führen
kann allein die tatsache dass wir sehr
schnell viele infizierte
haben könnten im januar im februar
könnte auch das gesundheitssystem wieder
vor eine für eine belastungsprobe
stellen allem voran hilft die impfung
die schützt zwar weniger gut vor einer
infektion mit omikron als vor einer mit
delta aber schwere krankheitsverläufe
vermeidet die spritze wohl ziemlich
zuverlässig ganz besonders der dritte
der booster packs impfen als wettlauf
gegen die zeit und gegen omikron
mit impfen allein ist es nicht getan
sagt der expertenrat bis das
breitflächig wirkung zeigt könnte es
schon zu viel zeit vergangen sein so
rasant wie die omikron variante sich
bewegt und auch geimpfte infizieren kann
deshalb lasse sich die verbreitung des
virus nach ansicht der experten nur
durch impfen nicht wirksam genug stoppen
aber das impfen vor allem das boostern
sorgt der nach jetzigem kenntnisstand
zumindestens dafür dass weniger menschen
so schwer erkranken dass sie in kliniken
müssen diese zusammenhänge haben
offenbar auch sehr viele menschen nach
verzogen der andrang in arztpraxen und
im station ist aktuell großer schärfe
berichtet
endlich mal wieder in den club getanzt
wird zwar nicht aber geimpft dieser
technoclub in der münchner innenstadt
macht mit beim marathon in cafés clubs
und theatern an der bar wird aufgezogen
stadt eingeschenkt und man kann einfach
rein schneiden vor oder nach dem
einkaufsbummel bis zehn uhr abends
gesagt habe ich vor ungefähr einer
halben stunde bei instagram gesehen als
werbung genau und dann bin ich einfach
spontan vorbei gekommen und ich finde
die atmosphäre halt es ist halt lockerer
als im im zentrum vor allem wenn man
einfach probleme hatte überhaupt termine
zu bekommen also hier ging es jetzt
super super schnell und ja die helden
schwer das auf jeden fall wissen weiter
unten die beats im hintergrund machen
schon das aufklärungsgespräch viel
angenehmer und in der bar gibt es
hinterher den stempel in den impfpass
die idee stammt von florian schönhofer
der auch den impfstoff besorgte und in
dessen café in den letzten zwei wochen
6000 leute geimpft wurden der ansturm
wird immer immer größer die ganze zeit
wir haben die jungs die sind 20
trinken und käppi und so und eigentlich
so die staaten haben die aber
verunsichert waren die ganze zeit und
die teufel getan hätten und in
irgendeinem zentrum gehen oder zum arzt
ging es machen die nicht kohlen und die
haben wir ganz gut abgebaut
deutschlandweit hat das im tempo in der
letzten woche angezogen der leiter des
neuen corona krisenstabes generalmajor
breuer zeigt sich zuversichtlich das
ziel von 30 millionen impfungen bis
jahresende zu schaffen ich glaube dann
ist das ziel nicht nur realistisch
sondern auch erreichbar aber und das ist
mir sehr wichtig dann dürfen wir nicht
aufhören sondern es muss über das jahr
hinaus gehen über den jahreswechsel
hinaus gehen und es muss eine
nachhaltigkeit hergestellt werden
schlusslicht bei der impfquote ist nach
wie vor sachsen doch obwohl das buch
dann auch hier inzwischen gut läuft
bleibt das tempo zu langsam sagt der
görlitzer infarkt hans christian
gottschalk wir kommen einfach nicht vor
die welle wir sind immer hinter der
welle und das heißt dass unsere niedrige
impfquote uns jetzt auf die füße fällt
wir haben noch nicht bewältigt foto
micon ist schon da im oberbayerischen
landkreis traunstein bis vor kurzem
corona hot spot wurde heute eine kirche
zum ins zentrum die impfung sei ein akt
der nächstenliebe sagt der pfarrer und
der leiter des örtlichen impfzentrum
schickte seine mitarbeiter gern zum
advents impfen
die signalwirkungen dass man sieht auch
die kirche ist mit dabei und auch so
sakraler raum ist dafür geeignet so was
zu tun das gehört einfach dazu und dann
wird es wieder ganz weltlich nach der
impfung gibt es einen glühwein für alle
[Musik]
aktuelle informationen und hintergründe
zum thema finden sie bei uns natürlich
wie immer auch online auf zdf heute
darin auch ein überblick über die
aktuell gültigen reisebeschränkungen die
es jetzt ja auch wieder gibt
um 20 uhr zwei erschlugen heute die
glocken in der berliner gedächtniskirche
am breitscheidplatz
im gedenken an das was vor fünf jahren
um diese uhrzeit geschah als der
attentäter mit einem sattelschlepper auf
den weihnachtsmarkt raste zwölf menschen
hat er damals getötet und vielen
weiteren ihr leben für immer brutal
verändert vor knapp zwei monaten starb
zudem ein dreizehntes opfer an den
spätfolgen seiner verletzungen es war
der bislang schwerste islamistische
terror anschlag in deutschland und zu
dem entsetzen über die tat reihte sich
später ja auch noch das entsetzen über
ermittlungsfehler im vorfeld die
aufarbeitung ist insofern bis heute
nicht abgeschlossen das macht es auch
hinterbliebenen überlebenden und
ersthelfern noch schwerer mit dem trauma
umzugehen lassen während und henriette
de maizière berichten aus berlin
ein glockenschlag für jedes opfer 13 mal
ertönt die glocke der berliner
gedächtniskirche
hinterbliebene verletzte helfer und die
politik erinnern gemeinsam an den
schwersten islamistischen anschlag in
deutschland
jedes jahr kommt sascha klösters auf den
weihnachtsmarkt auf dem breitscheidplatz
hier wurde er bei dem anschlag vor fünf
jahren schwer verletzt seine mutter
starb neben ihm seither ist ausgerechnet
der glühweinstand für ihn zu einem ort
des alljährlichen gedenkens geworden
es ist und bleibt nach wie vor schwierig
diesen ort hier zu betreten sobald ich
diesen gräbern stand sie
da kommen halt die erinnerung wieder und
allgemein ist es nicht einfach es ist
für mich aber wichtig trotzdem hier zu
sein und mir das doch nur alles
anzuschauen
19 dezember 2016 der attentäter eines
amri raste mit einem lkw auf den
weihnachtsmarkt der mann war lange im
visier der behörden doch zuständigkeit
pannen fehleinschätzung personalmangel
führten dazu dass er seine tat
ungehindert ausführen konnte hannes amri
gerät aus dem blick so stefan lenz der
den inzwischen abgeschlossenen
untersuchungsausschuss des berliner
abgeordnetenhauses leitete hingegen der
tatsächlichen entwicklung des ami hat
sich in den sicherheitsbehörden eine
einschätzung breit gemacht der amri
kühlt sich so zu sorgen ab weil er sich
verwirklicht weil er ja alkohol trinkt
drogen konsumiert das war falsch ist
eine falsche einschätzung
gleich nach der tat wurde klar
deutschland war auf den umgang mit einem
solchen anschlag nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet die hinterbliebenen beklagen
jetzt in einem offenen brief an die neue
bundesregierung
nach wie vor vermissen wir einen
würdigen umgang mit den betroffenen und
hinterbliebenen des anschlags sowie
dessen umfassende aufklärung
der 19 dezember 2016 er teile das leben
der angehörigen und das bewusstsein der
gesellschaft in ein davor und ein danach
so bundespräsident steinmeier heute bei
der gedenkveranstaltung
der staat hat sein versprechen auf
schutz
auf sicherheit und freiheit nicht
einhalten können es steht in ihrer
schuld
in der schulte opfer der verletzten und
ihre angehörigen
steht auch in der pflicht die fehler
versäumnisse und probleme auszuräumen
die dazu beigetragen haben dass dieser
anschlag nicht verhindert werden konnte
es habe fehler gegeben räumt steinmeier
ein fehler die korrigiert werden müssten
damit das vertrauen in den staat wieder
wachsen könne das wünscht sich auch
sascha klösters denn der anschlag auf
den weihnachtsmarkt sagt er sei ein
ereignis das sich tief in seinen
lebenslauf eingeschrieben habe
kosten während es uns jetzt vom
breitscheidplatz zugeschaltet von genau
der stelle wo er auch vor fünf jahren
stand als unser erster reporter am
anschlagsort der uns zunächst nur über
das handy berichten konnte wir sehen
hier auch noch einmal bilder von damals
lassen was ist ihnen am stärksten
erinnerung geblieben von diesen ersten
momenten als sie damals eintrafen
naja erstmal haben wir gerade ja die
serie oder ein erlebnis wie damals denn
just vor unser gespräch ist die rück
verbindung abgebrochen und ich stehe
jetzt wieder mit dem handy hier mit dem
knopf im ohr wie damals es ist wieder so
ein nasskalter tag hier in berlin und
ich erinnere mich wir uns die polizisten
hierher geführt haben an diesen ort und
der erste eindruck wir sind so nah am
geschehen weil der lastwagen war gerade
mal vielleicht zu 150 200 meter von uns
entfernt
es wurden dort noch verletzte behandelt
als wir eingetroffen sind einer von
denen übrigens wie ich später erfahren
habe war sascha klöster sind wir eben im
beitrag kennengelernt haben ja es war
blaulicht hier viele krankenwagen und
das lag über diesen platz eine enorme
stille also ganz anders als ich es mir
vorgestellt hätte wenn ein
terroranschlag passiert es war einfach
total ruhig
wenn man auf das jahr 2016 noch einmal
zurückblicken das war ein jahr in dem
die terrorgefahr eigentlich
allgegenwärtig war und trotzdem hatte
man den eindruck start und auch die
stadt berlin waren eigenartig
unvorbereitet auch und gerade im umgang
mit opfern und ihren angehörigen
ja so jetzt habe ich sogar doppelt
gehört ja es war tatsächlich eine große
unvorbereitet haitis kommt mir ein
bisschen vor wie bei corona die
deutschen sind wahnsinnig gut darin
pläne zu machen um chaos zu verhindern
aber wenn dann mal chaos ausbricht dann
ist der plan weg und das war ihm damals
auch so ein beispiel oder ein paar
beispiele dafür gerade am anfang der
gedenkgottesdienst der offizielle war
schon zwei tage nach dem anschlag da
waren viele der todesopfer noch gar
nicht identifiziert die verletzten in
den krankenhäusern und die waren daneben
gar nicht eingeladen oder wussten noch
gar nichts von ihrem schicksal so dass
das schon eine entfremdung stattgefunden
hat dann war es so dass die tatwaffe
lastwagen von der deutschen gesetzgebung
für terror nicht vorgesehen war das
wurde als verkehrs unfall eingestuft und
die betroffenen bekamen dann mögen für
verkehrsunfallopfer in die sie dann das
kennzeichen des unfallverursachers
eintragen sollten oder etwas später dann
serienbriefe ein schreiben vom
bundeskriminalamt
die sie unvorbereitet trafen und da
waren dann zum beispiel die zahnbürste
drin oder die
die haarspange die für die dna-probe
eingereicht wurde mit dem dank für die
mitarbeit sowas hat halt immer wieder
für retraumatisierung gesorgt und eben
auch für eine große enttäuschung beim
umgang bei dem die empathie bei den
bleibt bei vielen behörden bis heute
fehlt sie begleiten wir seitdem die
hinterbliebenen die sich organisiert
haben und einen bemerkenswerten
zusammenhalt pflegen also auch über
nationale grenzen hinweg denn es gab ja
opfer auch aus anderen ländern zum
beispiel aus polen oder oder aus israel
ja das stimmt ich konnte für meinen film
berlin breitscheidplatz leben nach dem
anschlag vor allem im ersten jahr die
hinterbliebenen begleiten das war ein
vertrauensverhältnis das sich nach und
nach entwickelt hat und ich erinnere
mich noch an einen moment nach einem
halben jahr da haben sie eine andacht
organisiert in brandenburg an der havel
wo eine familie gelebt hat oder immer
noch lebt und die angehörigen standen
der im kleinen kreis zusammen und zum
ersten mal wurden damals die namen der
getöteten verlesen es gab bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt keine offizielle trauerfeier
wo wirklich nochmal die verstorbenen
oder die ermordeten gewürdigt worden
sind und es war auch ganz spannend weil
eine einige haben ganz interessante
rituale entwickelt um mit der trauer
umzugehen der vater von sascha klösters
zb der hat früher baumärkte beliefert
und hat dann ist dort wieder
zurückgekehrt als rentner und hat
schrauben sortiert den ganzen tag und
heute gestern haben uns wieder getroffen
hat dieser kassen ich sollte hier immer
noch schrauben und was diese gruppe
geschafft hat ist dass sie eine
unheimliche politische kraft auch
entwickelt hat dann unheimlichen willen
nicht zuletzt an die ihres einsatzes
wurden die entschädigungszahlungen für
opfer erhöht der die versorgungsträger
haben bei der opferrente
wollen sie eben unter druck gesetzt und
die hinterbliebenen sind auch in die
untersuchungsausschüsse gegangen es gab
ja drei in nrw wo der attentäter lange
gelebt hat in berlin und im bund sind
dorthin gegangen haben mit den
politikern gesprochen und sie immer
wieder an das versprechen der in nadja
lückenlos aufzuklären kasten danke für
diese schilderung vom breitscheidplatz
und
jetzt mach erst mal kaiser richter
weiter mit den nachrichten da schauen
wir noch mal auf die pandemie die gegner
der korona maßnahmen werden offenbar
gewaltbereiter selbst tödliche angriff
erhält verfassungsschutzpräsident
haldenwang für möglich kein szenario sei
auszuschließen sagte er den funke
zeitungen in nürnberg zogen heute mehr
als 10.000 sogenannte querdenker durch
die stadt außerdem fand dort eine
kundgebung der afg stadt aber auch mehr
als 2000 gegendemonstranten waren auf
der straße bereits gestern hatte es in
zahlreichen städten proteste gegeben
bei einem besuch in litauen hat
verteidigungsministerin lambrich den
baltischen staaten zur legalität
zugesichert ihre erste reise führe sie
bewusst nach litauen sagte sie bei einem
besuch deutscher soldaten dort die teil
einer nato mission sind der konflikt mit
moskau müsse diplomatisch gelöst werden
es bedürfe aber auch einer glaubhaften
abschreckung russland hatte truppen an
die ukrainische grenze verlegt und von
der nato sicherheits garantien gefordert
bei amerikanischen drohnenangriffen im
nahen osten hat es offenbar deutlich
mehr zivile opfer gegeben als die
us-regierung zugibt das berichtet die
new york times nach der auswertung
vertraulicher dokumente der drohnenkrieg
sei von mangelhafter aufklärung fehlern
und tausenden zivilen todesopfern
geprägt viele von ihnen seien kinder
innerhalb von fünf jahren hat das us
militär im irak in syrien und
afghanistan insgesamt über 50.000
luftangriffe geflogen
nach dem wirbelsturm auf den philippinen
zählen die behörden mehr als 140 tote
und die zahl könnte noch steigen denn
viele orte sind noch immer nicht
erreichbar fast zwei tage lang hatte
taifun reihe auf den südlichen mittleren
inseln gewütet ganze sprecher sind
verwüstet
inzwischen ist frei kurz vor vietnam
angekommen dort bringen sich tausende
anwohner in sicherheit während die armee
provisorische dämme baut
sie nennen es parlamentswahlen aber
freie wahl haben die menschen in
hongkong nicht es ist die erste wahl
seit der niederschlagung der
demokratiebewegung wir gegenüber der von
peking gesteuerten regierungspartei ein
zeichen setzen will bleibt vielleicht am
besten einfach zu hause in scheinen
demokratien lässt sich der falschen
schein halt noch am ehesten durch eine
blamabel niedrige wahlbeteiligung
vorführen deshalb hatte die regierung
von hongkong aufrufe zum wahlboykott mit
drakonischen strafen belegt und trotzdem
beteiligten sich nur rund 30 prozent
voller berichtet
das chinesische staatsfernsehen
vermeldet stolz nur wer hongkong liebt
darf heute gewählt werden denn
zugelassen sind nur sogenannte patrioten
als kandidatin die loyal zu pekings
machthaber stehen und sie bestimmt sehr
patriotisch carol m die regierungschefin
von hongkong und die statthalterin von
peking verkündet schon während der wahl
den triumph
ich habe klare ziele für die wahl
definiert wir wollten sicherstellen dass
nur patrioten hongkong verwalten und das
haben wir erreicht
es macht viel arbeit diese wahl zum
erfolg aufzuhübschen kostenlos fahren
taxis bürger zur stimmabgabe
das staatsfernsehen zeigt lange
schlangen vor den wahllokalen
sie sollen die unterstützung der
hongkonger belegen aber unsere aktuellen
bilder zeigen dass es wohl wesentlich
weniger menschen sind die ihre stimme
abgeben nicht zu wählen ist die einzige
möglichkeit gegen diese wahl show zu
protestieren wer die abschaffung der
demokratie kritisiert will unerkannt
bleiben
ich bin so enttäuscht und ganz ohne
hoffnung
komplett
nichts ist mehr übrig geblieben von der
freiheitsbewegung in hongkong verstummt
sind die demokratischen abgeordneten dem
sommer 2020 gegen das nationale
sicherheitsgesetz kämpften dass jede
kritik an peking zum terror erklärte das
schicksal der letzten frei gewählten
abgeordneten zeigt das ausmaß der
unterdrückung vier sind ins ausland
geflohen zwölf sitzen im gefängnis fünf
sind auf kaution frei im internet
unterstützen viele den aufruf des
hongkonger ray home last meinen
kandidaten frei
niemand kann mir den willen der
hongkonger zum ausdruck bringen dieses
parlament ist ein pseudo parlament ohne
macht und funktion
präsident chief erfolgt dennoch mit
dieser wahl schon einen plan er will
seinem autoritären akt ein
demokratisches deckmäntelchen umhängen
peking hat sich vorgenommen demokratie
neu zu definieren sie wollen der welt
vormachen hongkong ging es besser diese
wahl gehört zur inszenierung
hongkong hat mit dieser wahl seinen
sonderstatus endgültig verloren pekings
machthaber haben die stadt auf linie
gebracht
die nächsten großen peking
inszenierungen werden wir dann wohl bei
den olympischen winterspielen zu sehen
bekommen aber dafür können natürlich die
athleten nichts und mit dem wintersport
wir das jetzt ein ereignisreiches
wochenende zu ende gegangen bei dem auch
heute vieles klappte bei den deutschen
sportlern zum beispiel im eiskanal und
auf der schanze bobpilotin khimki und
ihre anschieberin lisa burk wirklich
gewinnen das weltcup rennen in altenberg
im ziel sind sie rund zwei zehntel
schneller als ihre teamkolleginnen maria
janka und kira lipperheide bei den
männern ist francesco friedrich im
viererbob nicht zu stoppen der
zweimalige olympiasieger sichert sich
den insgesamt 62 weltcuperfolg seiner
karriere bei den rotweinen lässt die
formstarke julia taubitz im eiskanal der
konkurrenz keine chance die 25 jahren
alte oberwiesenthalerin triumphiert beim
weltcup in innsbruck weil sie im zweiten
lauf die österreicherinnen madeleine
eckle noch abfängt
mit vinzenz geiger eric frenzel und
terence weber belegen die deutschen
kombinierer beim weltcup in ramsau die
plätze zwei bis vier ein tolles
team-ergebnis wieder einmal nicht zu
schlagen der norweger magnus rieber der
seinen vorsprung in der gesamtwertung
damit ausbaut
gelungene generalprobe für karl geiger
vor der vierschanzentournee
135 und 131,5 meter reichen dem
weltcup-führenden beim springen in
engelberg für platz zwei hinter dem
japaner kobayashi
schauen wir auf die fußball bundesliga
und die beiden letzten spiele der
hinrunde da gewann köln zu hause gegen
stuttgart 1 zu 0 und freiburg gegen
leverkusen 2 zu 1 damit überwintern die
breisgauer erstmals auf einem champions
league platz
zum ersten mal in der geschichte des
deutschen profifußballs ist ein spiel
wegen einer rassistischen attacke
abgebrochen worden beim drittliga spiel
in duisburg wurde aaron apropos vom vfl
osnabrück offenbar von einem zuschauer
beleidigt der schiedsrichter unterbrach
die partie danach blieben beide
mannschaften in der kabine auch die fans
zeigten ihre solidarität die polizei
erstattete anzeige gegen den
mutmaßlichen täter
richard rogers galt als einer der
einflussreichsten architekten der welt
geballter von 88 jahren ist denn nun
gestorben er schuf einige der
bekanntesten bauwerke der welt unter
anderem das holtrup pompidou in paris
dabei verlegte er das komplette
versorgungssystem nach außen der brite
arbeitete bis ins hohe alter so
verwirklichte er vor dreieinhalb jahren
noch dieses projekt
für die menschen im aartal wird es das
erste weihnachten seit der
flutkatastrophe
besonders schwer für die die angehörige
verloren haben aber auch der verlust von
heimat haus und hof lastet auf vielen
sälen im schwer zerstörten schuld hat
angela hat eine frau getroffen die sich
all dem mit sehr viel tatkraft
entgegenstemmt und mit einer besonderen
leidenschaft
sie kann ihre finger nicht vom teig
lassen cornelia schlosser ist bäckerin
aus leidenschaft
die 52 jährige hilft zurzeit in einer
anderen bäckerei auf ihre eigene
backstube ist den fluten an der ahr zum
opfer gefallen bis vor kurzem stand eine
hauptstraße in schulden betrieb jetzt
gibt es hier nur noch eine große
baugrube
rückblick im vergangenen sommer die
flutwelle hatte die traditionsbäckerei
voll erwischt zunächst hoffte cornelia
schlosser ihr gebäude retten zu können
doch die wende hatten die verseuchte
brühe aufgesaugt also abriss die
bäckerin darf an dieser stelle wieder
aufbauen noch wie er aber die
information wie viel geld sie von der
versicherung bekommen wird damit sie
planen können
fenster rein gucken kann dann werden
natürlich noch besser sie nutzt das
angebot einer kostenlosen erstberatung
durch einen architekten wie kann man
neubauten im überschwemmungsgebiet gegen
hochwasser schützen da gibt es halt auch
möglichkeiten es halt dieses ausweisen
hat widerstand leisten oder man sagt
altmann lässt vielleicht sogar im
teilbereich hat wasser reihen als marke
bekennt sich dazu dass das wahr sein
kumpel magie das hat man am rhein oder
mosel und vielleicht hat man so nah und
cornelia schlosser vorstellungen
[Musik]
die leute kommen wieder da das so
so ein treffpunkt halt einen treffpunkt
den werden sie hier dringend brauchen
momentan steht in schuld vieles mehr die
menschen wohnen vorübergehend woanders
einige mussten abreißen
die umstände hier momentan schwierig
klar man ist froh dass man mit der
familie trotzdem geschehen noch
zusammensitzen kann aber man es halt
jeden tag auf baustellen er ist schon
weiter weihnachten wieder zu hause onkel
bisschen bordeaux fertig
und
[Musik]
wir wollen uns
auf dem dorfplatz von schuld haben sie
einen mächtigen weihnachtsbaum
aufgestellt zwölf meter hoffnung wie sie
sagen sie lassen sich nicht unterkriegen
mut werden sie die menschen im aartal
mit der flutkatastrophe im aartal werden
wir uns auch in der kommenden woche
beschäftigen damit beginnt der ausblick
von dara hassanzadeh
[Musik]
am montag wird der
untersuchungsausschuss zur
flutkatastrophe im aartal vor ort tagen
dabei werden die ausschussmitglieder in
den betroffenen gemeinden schuld und
altena der frage nachgehen welchen
einfluss die topografische und
geologische beschaffenheit des anteils
auf die flutkatastrophe hatte
am dienstag wird das berliner
abgeordnetenhaus einen neuen regierenden
bürgermeister wählen kurz wahrscheinlich
eine bürgermeisterin in person von
franziska die feier die spd gewannen die
berliner wahlen klar vor den grünen und
der cdu empfangen ihrer wahl wird geht
eine rot rot grüne koalition führen
am donnerstag wird russlands präsident
putin sich journalisten stellen auf
seiner jahrespressekonferenz die er eine
audienz gleich zur inszenierung gehören
auch kritische fragen und die art und
weise wie putin diese fragen nicht
beantwortet ist für nicht wenige
berichterstatter das heimliche highlight
dieses rituals
am freitag wird heiligabend seien frohes
fest
[Musik]
weniger weihnachtlich ist das wetter
aber immerhin wird es freundlicher bei
minus zwei bis plus sechs grad zeigt
sich die sonne morgen fast im ganzen
land im süden ist es noch anfangs nicht
bewölkt später wird es auch dort
freundlicher
in den folgenden tagen bleibt es kalt
mit viel sonne und nur wenig schnee erst
am donnerstag wird es spürbar
unbeständiger und auch milder das ganze
bei minus zwei bis plus 9 grad
das war es von uns weiter geht es mit
den sportlern des jahres festlich gekürt
im kurhaus in baden-baden wir wünschen
einen schönen abend bis bauen
wiedersehen
[Musik]